Ce qui est bien quand on part à la découverte de nouvelles contrées, c'est le
dépaysement! TOUT CHANGE! Les gens, la langue, les modes de vies ,
les paysages, et ....
et votre transite intestinale ... Tout l'été
DTC vous aide
à éviter les pièges et les dangers qui menacent votre bien-être et votre santé.
DTC , partenaire de votre été! Cet été si vous voyagez
vous aurez peut être la chance de découvrir cette petite espièglerie
qui pimente les séjours à l'étranger qu'on appelle
la tourista!
*musique*
Non..non ça c'est la Lambada. Moi, je parle de la tourista, la diarrhée du
voyageur. Et si vous ne voyagez pas, bah regardez la vidéo quand même
car c'est fort cocasse !
*genérique DTC*
La diarrhée du voyageur! La tourista!
Si vous préférez, enfin si vous préférez ..
Façon de parler ! C'est drôle, non?De classifier une diarrhée
en fonction de l'activité de la personne  qui la subit.. Je veux dire
ça existe la diarrhée du pécheur ?  *bruit de diarrhée*
La diarrhée du joggeur ? *bruit de diarrhée*
D'ailleurs ça n'est pas le seul nom fleurit qu'on donne à la tourista.
On l'appelle aussi la "complainte de l'été"
la "course de Turquie" ,la "danse aztèque", le "galop grec".
etc.. etc.. Moi j'aime bien!
Mais bon, on est pas là pour déclamer du Rimbaud,
on est là pour parler chiasse, alors allons-y!
LA TOURISTA C'EST QUOI? Alors contrairement à ce que dis la légende,la tourista ce n'est pas une réaction aux plats épicés. Et ce n'est pas dû à un
"changement de régime alimentaire". Rien à voir non plus avec une
malédiction qui frapperait les étrangers pour les éloigner
d'un lieu sacré ou avec l'esprits des anciens qui se vengent
du bétonnage de leurs terres ou que sais-je..
En réalité la tourista, c'est une intoxication alimentaire.
Ni plus, ni moins. Une gastro entérite aigüe, c'est-à-dire une
inflammation de l'ensemble du tube digestif causé
dans la majorité des cas, par un germes qu'on a avalé.
Parmi les bactéries en causes, au premier rang, les bactéries fécales.
Et notamment les "escherichia coli" dont on avait déjà
parlé dans une vidéo précédente. Je vous la remets en description.
Donc oui , là on est en train de parler de bactéries contenues dans le caca..
que vous avalez du coup..
J'ai conscience que ça fait pas envie, mais
En fait on a beaucoup plus de risque de choper la tourista dans les pays
où le niveau d'hygiène est bas. Elle se déclenche souvent dans
les trois premiers jours du voyage, ou tout à la fin
parce qu'on croit qu'on est sorti d'affaire alors on fait un peu moins attention.
Elle dure 2 ou 3 jours, parfois plus. Et autant vous dire
que les randos tourista, les sports nautiques les fesses serrées
ou les trajets en avion, c'est bof..
Alors le mieux c'est de prendre ses précautions.
Comment éviter la tourista?
Alors c'est clair pour tout le monde, c'est au niveau
de la nourriture et des boissons que ça se passe ,
mais pas que..
Voilà 7 conseils pour éviter...
Vous voyez quoi.. le...
La cuisson tue les germes !
Donc vérifier que vos aliments sont bien cuits
et qu'ils sont encore chauds avant de les manger.
Évitez les crudités.
Et si vraiment vous voulez manger des fruits, épluchez les !
NE BUVEZ QUE DES BOISSONS EN BOUTEILLES ENCAPSULÉES! Et vérifiez bien
le bruit qu'elles font quand vous les ouvrez
NE PRENEZ PAS DE GLAÇONS, car c'est de l'eau du robinet à tout les coups. Et évitez les glaces
et les sorbets aussi. Les œufs et les produits laitiers
risquent de contenir des germes bien costauds dont des salmonelles donc..
laissez tomber. Brossez vous les dents avec de l'eau en bouteille ou
emmenez des produits pour désinfecter l'eau avant. Et évitez des laisser couler de l'eau dans votre bouche grande ouverte,
quand vous prenez la douche hein..
Je sais qu'il y en a qui le font...
SUPER IMPORTANT! Lavez vous les mains
le plus souvent possible!
Et évitez de les mettre dans votre bouche.
Ou dans la bouche de qui que ce soit d'ailleurs... Et quand c'est trop tard
on fait quoi ? Alors on fait quoi ?
Bah on chie en spray dans un premier temps
et puis on va chercher une nouvelle muqueuse anale sur Ebay au bout de 2 jours à peu près..
Mais surtout la première chose à faire c'est de BOIRE BEAUCOUP!
Alors des petites quantités pour pas ..
Mais souvent. Pour pas se déshydrater.
OUI! De l'eau ! Bien sur! ET de l'eau en bouteille!
Vous êtes déjà en mode coulée de lave, vous allez pas en rajouter!
De l'eau en bouteille! Il faut manger aussi !
Pas trop.. mais il faut manger aussi! Essentiellement
du riz et des bananes, si vous voulez. En attendant que ça se tasse.
Comme vous êtes prévoyant, bah vous avez apporté des médicaments!
C'est le moment de les prendre. Il y en a de plusieurs types: les anti-diarrhéiques
les anti-infectieux-intestinaux, les pansements gastriques
Parlez-en à votre médecins avant de partir, et
passez chez le pharmaciens après. Si les symptômes s'aggravent,
si vous avez beaucoup de fièvres, si il y a du sang dans votre caca,
allez voir un médecin. Bon, ça je suis presque sûr
que vous y auriez penser tout seul, mais, ce qui va sans dire
va encore mieux en le disant. Et puis une fois que le plus dur
est derrière vous,
REDOUBLEZ DE VIGILANCE.
Mais ça c'est pareil, je suis sûr que  vous avez pas très envie que ça recommence.
VOILA! DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui! Je vous souhaites un très bel été! Plein de..
Plein de joie, et d’allégresse! On se retrouve dans
2 semaines pour une nouvelle vidéo spéciale été, d’ici là,
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous bien!